أه أقول إن العلاقة مع
السعودية علاقة مهمة فلدينا
مصالح كبيرة أه مستمرة وما
زلنا ملتزمين بالدفاع أه
عن المملكة
أه لكننا نريد التأكد
وهذا ما قاله الرئيس
منذ البداية
أن  العلاقة تعكس بشكل أفضل
اهتماماتنا
وقيمنا وأه لذا فإن ما
فعلناه بالأفعال التي اتخذناها
أه هو في الحقيقة ليس لقطع
العلاقة ولكن إعادة معايرتها
لتكون أكثر انسجاما مع اهتماماتنا أه وقيمنا
و  أه أعتقد أن أه علينا أن
نفهم أيضًا أن
هذا أكبر من أي
شخص أه هذا إعادة المعايرة تذهب
إلى السياسات التي تنتهجها المملكة العربية السعودية
والإجراءات التي يتم اتخاذها شيء واحد سريع
على محمد
سلمان هل يمكننا أن نزال  تعامل
معه
كما قلت سابقًا ، إن العلاقة
مع المملكة العربية السعودية أكبر من
أي فرد تعامل معه الرئيس
كما تعلم مع الملك سلمان لقد تحدثت
إلى
نظيري الأجنبي  تحدث الوزير
والسكرتير أوستن إلى
نظيره الذي صادف أنه محمد
بن
سلمان